Hey you!
Thanks for coming and joining us.
>> Hey, thanks, [CROSSTALK].
>> Appreciate you spending some time.
Have a seat,
we'll go through our prototype here.
So we're beginning a project here that
is a bit of an event management app.
Think about it like to dos,
events, that kind of thing.
I'm curious to get your feedback
on the general flow of the app.
But I'm also curious to get your
feedback on some very specific things.
So for instance, in taking a look at,
you can see here that we have a screen
where we can create new events.
But I'm kind of curious to
understand from the home screen,
when you first come into the app,
do you see something that stands out for
you that would draw you to go ahead and
create a new event?
>> Sure, so there is a big
red plus there and it's red.
So I am looking at it and
that matches a lot of other designs
on Android that is a material design.
I am not really familiar with
a whole bunch of other places.
So if I was at this screen,
I would hit that plus and
expect to create an event.
I'm not sure whether that would
necessarily create an event right here
where it shows the date as the 25th, or
whether that would create an event that
it was left to fill the date,
but that's what I would expect.
>> Yeah, you know you bring
up a great point, right?
Sensible defaults in the creation screen
would make a lot of sense for us.
In that case, like inserting the date.
Because we've come
from a specific event,
specific screen here
that lists the date.
>> Like on this screen,
where it looks like this is a day view.
Yeah, and so
here the plus I would definitely
expect it to create that default.
>> Yeah, so the pattern there
is a floating action button.
We see that pattern actually
repeat itself a little bit through
the app here.
One question for you, the footing action
button tends to move around a little bit
within the UI though.
Would you consider that to be
a jarring part of the experience?
Or do you feel that you understand
the action of the button
irregardless of where it's
positioned in the screen?
>> So I see it in three places here.
Here and
here which are basically the same.
There's no real difference there.
And here at the bottom.
And it's nice to get it
out of the way here.
I think that's sort of where I expect it
based on using a bunch of other apps.
And likewise, here, presumably, this
screen is going to move up and down.
And it will stay in this interface,
the border between the header and
the actual list of events.
That makes sense to me.
>> Yeah, we're contemplating
implementing some really nice
animations as you scroll
through this screen, so
it's possible that the fab
might grow and shrink.
It might disappear as you scroll up
through the list, but we want to keep
the context in tab headers as
we progress through the views.
Because it's important that you
maintain that information, right,
that you be able to swap between
the week and month very quickly.
Now in looking at the fab
on this particular page,
on the week page, one of the things
we've seen in the past is that
The fab can get in the way
of some of the content.
Do you feel that that's
really a problem for us here?
>> I feel like right now where
it is at the bottom right,
it's going to cover something.
>> You mean it doesn't cover that much?
Mostly avatars in this screen right now.
>> Yeah.
Also given how many items
are being displayed and
the fact that the user is going
to have to scroll through but
can see roughly three or four at
a time anyway, it seems to make sense.
It could not exist at all.
But that doesn't seem like
that would be better.
>> Okay.
So given that this is an event slash
2D management app, one of the things
that we really want to make sure that
users can do is actually check off and
complete those tasks.
Do you see a clear way to do
that within these screens?
>> Hm, I don't see anything that
actually says that this is to-dos
at all.
Like all of this looks like
a calendar and event stuff to me.
>> Interesting.
>> Everything here has a time,
it looks like it all has places as well.
The idea of there being, there's no
checkboxes, no indication that these
are things that could be accomplished as
another to do list, so I don't see that.
>> Interesting.
And so, if I were to direct you
over here to these check boxes,
these UI elements.
Do you feel that that's
obviously when you walk
through the screens here
that was a miss, right?
>> Mm-hm.
>> How do feel that we can evolve
that to make that a little bit more
prominent, to make that functionality
standout just a bit more?
It's a core part of
the experience that we want here.
And so, we need to do a better
job of showcasing that feature.
>> I'm not sure that the circular
check box would be as good as
a square check box.
Usually when we check off
things in most applications,
there's an empty square
that gets checked,
as opposed to a gray circle that
changes color and has that in there.
I think it's also a little bit
deceptive how this is displayed.
Very much as sort of calendar
events that have locations and
times, which to-do lists certainly
can have locations and times, but
the thing to do is often, by far
the most relevant, rather than the time.
And so, I wouldn't normally
go through my calendar and
check off the events
that I actually went to.
Whereas with a to-do list manager,
having the check be more prominent
than the time would make sense.
>> Hm, interesting.
So certainly it sounds to me like you
feel that the affordance needs to be
stronger, but
there's also a question about whether or
not we're actually managing to-do's
versus calendar events here.
So perhaps the to-do aspect of
the app needs to stand out a bit more.
>> Right, so this here,
we have the exact same things.
And this very much
looks like a calendar.
There's no way of
checking something off.
>> Absolutely.
>> And this, we can check it off.
What does that do?
Does that remove it from our calendar?
I don't know.
>> Yeah,
I think that's a great question to ask,
is what would you expect to happen
when you did check something off?
Would you expect it to
disappear form your calendar?
Would you expect there to be
an animation associated with that?
Would you want to see it in place?
>> Yeah, if I'm using some
kind of a to-do list manager,
I think I do want something to
happen when I check it off.
And that probably means striking it out
in case it was an accidental check,
snd I don't want it to just
disappear immediately.
>> Oh yeah, good feedback.
>> Potentially it could move away and
be left with an undo.
But in this case, where these
obviously are calendar-ish things,
I don't want them removed
from my calendar.
I might want to go back and see them.
>> Absolutely, I think maintaining
some historical context here is really
important to actually managing the set
of events that are happening here.
Let me ask you one question.
In terms of gesture support for
this screen, how would you expect
a user to interact with this to
check something as completed.
Would you expect a tap, a swipe?
>> With this screen,
I would expect a tap to
bring up a screen that has more detailed
information, so something like this.
>> Oh, I see.
Like a detailed view.
>> [CROSSTALK] With these filled in so
you could.
So tap might bring it up to edit it.
I wouldn't expect you to check
it off unless the tap was on,
basically the check mark.
Which is why it might be
a good idea to have it larger.
This is a really small target area.
>> Yeah, and we really want to make
sure that we have a 40 dip tap target.
Making sure that we have 40
device independent pixels
is a valuable part of
touch responsiveness.
Making sure that we have enough room for
the finger on the screen.
>> I'm not totally sure what
a swipe left or right might do.
It's possible that you could
train users to do that but
it's not super intuitive what
the objective would actually be.
Swiping up or down definitely
should move through the list and
we can see things that are farther down.
>> So one of the things you also
mentioned was that there was some
consistency in the experience here.
One thing though is that we're only
allowing you to manage apps from
the day view.
Would you expect to want to be able
to manage those events from your home
screen as well?
Or is that more of like
a heads-up display?
>> Oh, you mean here you can check
them off and here you can't?
>> That's correct.
>> If to-do list management is
really a top level objective,
then probably doing that from
home screen is really important.
One of the things about to-do lists,
is people just won't use them if
it takes a long time to do things.
So taking an extra tab to get
through to a day view screen to
manage a to-do list, might keep
people from interacting with it.
>> Yeah, that does seem inefficient.
>> But again, here,
if I tapped on any of these items,
I would normally expect
to be taken to an edit.
Rather than able to complete.
Also it's weird here that you
can edit everything about this
potential item except whether
it's been accomplished or not.
So here you have to actually
be in this screen and
see the list to check items off,
it that's possible.
Whereas here you can edit
everything else, but not that.
>> There isn't even a notion of
delete yet here either, right?
>> Right.
>> Where would you expect to see delete?
Would you expect to see
that here with completion?
Here in the edit UI?
>> I would definitely expect it to be
in the edit UI someplace, because when
everything else fails, people are
probably going to go look for it there.
It also potentially is reasonable for
a swipe gesture to move this off and
delete it.
>> Interesting, so
maybe swipe one way to complete,
swipe another way to delete?
>> That is a method of interaction that
for instance, gets used on inbox, and
so I think this would be pretty
familiar to a lot of users.
>> Yeah, that in particular
swipe affordance is quite
popular in inbox as well, yeah.
Great, well I really
appreciate you coming out and
giving us a little bit
of feedback on the app.
You've definitely caught
some glaring issues for us.
We definitely need to iterate
here a little bit more.
But I would really appreciate getting
more feedback when we have iterated and
improved based on the feedback
that you've given.
Would you be willing to give us
more feedback in the future?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Great, thank you very much.